good morning everybody good afternoon
good evening depending on where you are
in the world welcome and thank you for
joining us for this webinar with mr.
Jeff Allen how the agile scrum master
training can give your career a leg up
for professionals that have not yet
adopted agile methods it's time to take
that leap because as a desired skills
from training opens the door to over
340,000 openings in the US alone with an
average take home of a hundred and three
thousand dollars so if you want to claim
your share of that opportunity Jeff is
here to show you the career and business
potential that can be unlocked with the
agile scrum master certification and
he'll explain how best it can give you
that career boost you're looking for if
you're not familiar with Jeff I want to
fix that right now he is a consultant
for National Business Administration
focusing on agile waterfall and hybrid
project management he has 35 years of
experience as a trainer presenter and
content developer and he has conducted
over 250 training sessions on agile
scrum master PMP pmi-acp and PMI RMP
exam prep for over 5,000 participants he
has held varied and important roles in
his career including vice president of
biz dev in HP executive director of the
California Commission on the US
bicentennial and director of the
National Center for Constitutional
studies a very experienced and wise
gentlemen we have here with us and we're
lucky to to be learning from them today
but before we get started I want to make
sure that everybody knows how their
dashboard works and that you're hearing
this okay so take a look at your
dashboard and find yourself the
questions module that's the spot where
you can type in a question this is not
the chat module but the question module
and just go ahead and type hello in
there for me if you would just say hi to
jeff and let us know that you can hear
us and you're excited to get rolling and
and ready to learn i see lisa says hello
there fantastic hi Rob and Richard and
event CEO terrific that tells me that
you
hear me Austin Texas Vianna you were
here with us yesterday i think i love
the barbecue in Austin that tells me you
can hear us okay and you know how to use
the questions module so that questions
module will remain your best friend if
you have questions during the
presentation this is where you type them
and we'll collect them all together and
Geoff we'll go ahead and do his
presentation front to back it's going to
take maybe 30 minutes and then we will
loop back around and we'll do the Q&A
and we'll hit as many questions of
viewers as we possibly can if you hear
something really incredible and wise and
awesome that you want to share and I
think it's likely you will go ahead and
share it on social if you want to you
can go ahead and live tweet or Facebook
or LinkedIn or whatever your preferred
channel is if you want to you can use
the hashtag SL webinars now to let
everybody know where you are what you're
learning and why they ought to be here
that's pretty much everything I've got
to say you know how to use your
questions module and you didn't come
here to listen to me so I'm going to
turn it over to Jeff and he's going to
lay down the wisdom you all just grab
yourselves a cup of coffee or try or
wine if it's the evening for you and
take a few notes and here we go thank
you Jeff for being here thanks Chet glad
to be here it's a pleasure you'll turn
it over to you sir okay thanks so team
welcome i'm glad you're here I don't
know where you are in your career but
the chances are that because you're here
with us this morning or this evening or
this afternoon or whatever it is you've
got some questions about how to best
advance in your career I've been doing
project management training for over 14
years and I just want to start by saying
that the simply learn organization is
the best organization i've had the
opportunity to be affiliated with and
chip said some nice things about me i
just want to say some nice thing nice
things about simply learned just to get
us started you can see on the screen
here that we have hundreds of courses
and every month tens of thousands of
people join us for new trainings and we
have a presence all across the war
and the platform that we work on is
global I am actually not in my office
right now I needed to travel so I'm set
up elsewhere and this is how it works
for you anywhere you are in the world at
any time you're going to have access to
the trainings that are going to help you
build your career and increase your
skills and abilities to not just serve
yourself but also your organization so
simply learn is actually not that old
we've been around just a few years you
can see here on the screen that we
started small and now we have a global
presence and we do trainings for a
multitude of organizations the one that
we're going to be focusing on today is
eggs in and they're ASM certification
agile scrum master but you may have
desires to do other trainings as well
and we've got you covered and our basic
thing is is if you want to get ahead the
needed to get certified and we're the
best place to help you with that now I
love project management and you know I
don't know if you've thought about this
or not but project management is really
simply the science about getting stuff
done and project management has
obviously been around for a long time
but think about this things historically
like the pyramids in Egypt the Roman
aqueducts the cathedrals in Europe the
first transcontinental railway in
America all of these are examples of
projects and it required people to
figure out how to get stuff done and
organizations across the world whether
it's for software or for building
buildings or you know jets or whatever
it is those are all projects in as chip
was saying the number of opportunities
for those that are certified and can
demonstrate they have
skill sets and the knowledge are almost
unlimited and we'll mention this a
couple of times like chip already did
your ability to earn money as a
certified ASM knowing about your
organization and how to actually run
agile projects is going to enable you to
make a lot more money than you would if
you were not sort of certified and it's
it's kind of funny you know a lot of
people don't like standardized testing
and they think you know certifications
are kind of silly when it comes to you
know how you prove that you have gotten
certified and you know that's not that
off the mark I suppose accept the
reality is is if you are in a position
to be hiring somebody what do you do you
look and see what the certifications are
and while it may not be the best
predictor of how you're going to do in
the real world it's where you start and
you've got to have it and as I'll
mention early a little bit later the
training course for ASM that we do here
it simply learn actually gets into the
how do i do a good job as opposed to
just what skills and knowledge do I need
to pass the exam so it's a very valuable
credential in goes beyond the scope of
some of the others that are available
right now but back the project
management we're a part of this
profession we like to get stuff done and
we like to work with people in order to
get that done and as a profession what
started as being something informally
practiced has now emerged as a distinct
profession probably around the 1950s or
so is where projects began to transition
from just being managed on an ad hoc
basis using some simple tools like Gantt
charts and other tools and techniques
and then morphing into an area
management area where
our specific tools techniques best
practices were being used and when we
get into the definition of a project and
how we end up fitting into all of this
by definition a project is a temporary
endeavor that results in something
unique so what you and I do in our
day-to-day jobs is not operations it's
not maintaining things although we may
have impact on operations and may
participate in maintenance what we do is
we take things that need to get done and
we start at the beginning and then we
help guide them through to completion
and whether we're developing a software
application or building a building or
expanding cells into a new market those
are all examples of projects that are
being run today and it's even possible I
imagine that some of you have been
involved in some of those kinds of
endeavors now as a project manager our
goal is to create for the customer what
it is the customer wants but it goes
beyond that because in order to have a
successful project you have to deliver
what the customer wants but you have to
do it on time and on budget and that
require skills now in the marketplace
right now there are two basic approaches
to project management there is waterfall
and agile and at a very high level the
differences are these waterfall is a
plan driven approach that favors
projects that have clear requirements in
focuses on the creation of a master plan
upfront and then measuring the actual
results to the plan in order to
determine the help of project as it goes
forward the agile approach focuses on
projects that are unclear
or have changing requirements and then
delivering value to the customer in
short frequent iterations now I got my
start in the waterfall world and i have
my PMP certification I've had it now for
many years well I don't know this to be
the case I would expect that some of you
also have your PMP and you're wondering
about getting into the agile world some
of you may be actually new to the whole
certification thing and you're wondering
where to begin I'll mention this again
in just a little bit but I believe that
there is value in both the waterfall
approach and the agile approach and
having gotten started in the waterfall
area first and then later being exposed
to agile I can tell you that the most
exciting way to get involved with
project management at least in my
opinion is to understand agile and be
able to practice it successfully in fact
just to kind of close that that concept
there I think that the project manager
the future is going to need to have a
waterfall certification and an agile
certification probably the most too
popular waterfall certifications would
be the PMP which is from PMI the project
management institute and then prince2
and prints to is more popular in the UK
and in Europe I don't see it much in the
United States at all so depending on
where you are and if you decide to also
get a lot of fall certification you
might choose between PMP or prints too
if you didn't want to do both of them
but whether or not you decide to get
certified in the waterfall the
traditional approach in today's world
there is no way that you can make what
you
have the potential of making and be able
to advance in your career unless you are
certified in agile and let me just go
here to the next slide here and the
reason that a July is emerging as being
so popular particularly when it comes to
the IT world and software development is
because the waterfall approach didn't
serve that community very well there
were three main problems that software
projects run into when you use the
traditional waterfall approach and one
is is that the burden of heavy
documentation and by heavy documentation
we mean the upfront planning the status
reports progress reports the upfront
requirements that are collected and
documented there's an enormous amount of
effort in a waterfall project that needs
to be done on the front end for it to be
successful but when you're doing
projects that have a high level of
uncertainty and are subject to a lot of
change like software development that
kind of documentation becomes a burden
and it's an impediment to success and
then secondly the frequent requirement
changes that are a part of projects that
are uncertain and the ability to react
to the changing requirements that the
customer has is very difficult in the
waterfall world with traditional world
not that it can't be done and it is done
but it's just not the way the most
effective way to do it so that's the
second issue that agile was developed to
address and then the last one is a poor
quality software and some of you might
be old enough to remember what that used
to be like you know I've been around for
a long time and I remember when you know
companies like Microsoft and Lotus and
other companies began emerging is these
huge
where companies and it was kind of a
joke to look at the first release or to
get the first release of the software
because they were so buggy and so part
of agile is to address the poor quality
software and when we get into agile we
discover that there are some techniques
and some best practices that have been
developed in the agile world that have
caused this quantum leap in the quality
and the number of software solutions
that are out there and that's what we're
involved in now let me just give you a
definition of agile written by Scott
ambler and if you have been involved in
agile at all you know the name Scott
ampere there's a there's a few people
that we call thought leaders in the
agile world that were a part of the you
know the emergence the creation of agile
and have contributed significantly to
the body of knowledge and Scott ambler
is one of these and this sentence right
here is one of the most information
knowledge pack sentences I've ever run
across so agile is an iterative and
incremental evolutionary approach to
project development which is performed
in a highly collaborative manner by
self-organizing teams with just enough
ceremony that produces high-quality
software in a cost effective and timely
manner which meets the changing needs of
its stakeholders and that's what we
cover in the ASM the agile scrum master
certification course we talked about how
agile is iterative and incremental
meaning things are done over and over in
a format way not that what's being done
is done over and over so the project
actually develops or unfolds in in
eville
shin area way it's done in a highly
collaborative manner and when you go
through the course you're going to learn
that collaborative and agile sets a very
high threshold doing things in a
collaborative way means that the team
and the customer in the scrum master are
actually going to achieve consensus
meaning everybody is agreed everybody is
on the same page before work gets done
and the skills that are necessary in
order to guide a team and the product
owner to a point of consensus is what
we're all about that's what we do we
cover those skills and techniques in the
course and it's it's it's magical to be
able to know how to be what we call a
servant leader and to be able to guide
an empowered self organizing team
without doing the work to having success
in becoming a high-performing team and
some of the greatest things that you'll
ever accomplish in your life and you
will love it and we cover that in the
course itself and then it says with just
enough ceremony ceremony think of that
as like a meeting or event in agile
there are certain meetings or events
that we do with every one of these
iterations and it's in these ceremonies
that we as the scrum masters use our
skills our tools and techniques to help
assure the success for both the product
owner and the team but we never go
beyond what's necessary it's just enough
ceremony it's much less than in the
waterfall world but as you get into the
course you'll see that it is far more
effective in the world of uncertain and
changing projects just very effective
and here it says also produce
high-quality software we'll get into
some of the best practices when it comes
to testing and we'll even share with you
testing prandtl that shows the type of
testing the amount of testing that's
done by the team and then by the
customer and even some exploratory
testing and other things and these are
best practices that have emerged and
you've got to know about them you don't
have to be an expert in them but you
have to know about them knowing they
should be used and know how to assist
the team in using them in order to
regularly consistently reliably produce
high-quality software and then of course
in a cost effective and timely manner
well we may not know the full scope of
the project on the front end and an
agile project we know that the business
folks right the suits are going to be
concerned about schedule and costings
and so we address how we do that in the
agile world as well and then in agile
our number one goal is to deliver to the
customer what the customer wants even if
the customer changes is or her mind late
in the project that's what we did so
this is this right here basically gives
you the agenda of our training as well
as getting you prepared to pass the exam
um just to compare why what's chip was
saying earlier about the number of
opportunities that are available it's
right here this is a study that was done
I guess it's about four years now that
looks at when it comes to projects that
are uncertain and changing in nature the
success rate in the waterfall
traditional approach versus agile and
just by looking at this here you can see
that any organization that wants to be
able to compete in today's marketplace
is going to want to do agile and agile
is not necessarily easy for an
organization to adopt one of the
advantages of the ASM course is we
actually have a whole section where we
cover agile adoption
javed option that we cover in the ASM
and is a part of a credential is not a
part of any of the other agile
certifications and I have a couple of
the other ones I love that aspect of the
ASM and I think it brings huge value to
organizations when you say I'm an ASM
because it's telling them that hey we
know that you are going to benefit from
using the agile approach and I have
skills and knowledge to assist in that
transition that journey to go from the
waterfall to an agile organization and
you are tested on that too and so we
cover it we cover it in a way that gives
you the ability to you know have an idea
what would need to be done and then also
passed the exam so that you know your
organization you work for now or another
one in the future will know that you
have that background when it comes to a
little bit more granular view of the
difference between waterfall and agile
let's just go over this chart quickly
when it comes to the planning approach
and waterfall as I mentioned earlier the
emphasis is on upfront plan in agile the
emphasis is on ongoing plan in waterfall
there are detailed requirements that are
defined up front even before beginning
the design and development process in
agile the only upfront planning that's
done is a high level backlog a product
backlog which is really just a list of
things that the customer wants the
software to do and then an agile we
actually take the approach of deferring
planning decisions as long as possible
because the more you know the better
your decisions are going to be so the
deeper you are into the project the
better and veteran you are going to
actually be at your planning decisions
when it comes to communications in
waterfall its formal and its structured
and that serves traditional pride
it's very well you know where the
requirements are mostly known up front
it makes sense to be more formal and
structured in agile it's not going to
work that way in agile the focus is on
the people the folks that are involved
in the project and the interactions with
them and so it's informal but it's
constant it's 360 everybody's involved
and there's a whole set of skills that
go along with that and we cover those in
the course as well when it comes to
ceremonies remember we said ceremonies
are basically meetings or events in
waterfall there's a lot of project
ceremonies team meetings formal project
reviews documented status reports and a
focus on details in agile low project
ceremony we do have meetings but they're
limited we do project reviews but
they're very brief and the documented
status reports don't contain a lot of
details what we're really doing is we're
giving to the customer finished product
in increments and so we don't need a lot
of status reports we see here's what it
looks like we demo will let the customer
do acceptance testing and that's how the
project moves forward so in waterfall
the way progress is measured is with
artifacts and milestones in agile it's
by delivering working software to the
customer when it comes to change control
and water flow it's very formal and
there's even in most cases some kind of
a board or a group that actually has
control or authority over what changes
are going to be approved or rejected in
agile nothing like that exists if there
is any it's not formal it's all done
through that product backlog that I
mentioned and we'll teach you all about
that in the course but that's the tool
or what's contained in the product
backlog are the tools that enable the
team to know what the customer wants and
if the customer wants to change
something the customer gets to change
something
and we embrace it we say yay we get to
change something when it comes to scope
control in agile it's very formal and
it's important to do it in agile
projects because on the front end
everything figured out and so you can
come up with a predictable budget in a
predictable schedule and those become
the metrics that are used to determine
the health of the project in agile we
expect the scope to change and expand in
order to meet the needs of the customer
in agile we even embrace mid-course
Corrections meaning that into the
project the customer says you know where
I told you I wanted to end up at the
beginning I change my mind i actually
want to end up somewhere else but in
agile all right that's the agile means
being flexible right now this next chart
here is maybe going to help you decide
kind of where you and your organization
fit into all of this so we've got two
metrics here we've got requirements if
you look at the the vertical side on the
left here at the bottom when you begin a
project in there is a lot of agreement
meaning we know what the requirements
are and then at the top it's far from
agreement meaning there's some
requirements maybe even many that need
to be discovered as the project
progresses and then at the bottom we've
got technology and on the left close to
certainty meaning how we're actually
going to implement the project how we're
going to get it done how it's going to
work etc close to certainty you know
like building a building is a great
example of you know a project that fits
well in the waterfall world you're going
to have all the design box up front
right and for the most part what you do
in building a building has been done
before the ability to know what
technology to use how to do it it's
almost certain on the frame but then if
you go to the right we have the label
they're far from uncertainty and there
are projects where we don't know and the
you can see there that that green area
is the sweet spot for agile projects
things that we would label a simple you
know that's easily Noble or known and
then there's complicated it's not simple
but it's really knowable you can get
there fairly easily when we get in the
agile area this is the complex area and
that's where it's not fully knowable on
the front end it's reasonably
predictable the direction we're going to
go but we still have to discover a lot
about it going forward and then we have
chaos up there at the top right and
those are projects where it's not
knowable and it's not predictable and
there are no real project management
approaches that address that kind of a
project but if you were to go out and
research you know agile and waterfall
you would see that you know these four
types of projects are addressed so the
the world that we live in and agile is
that green area right there now we
talked about credentialing a bit and I
mentioned already that obviously there
is a place in the project management
world for both waterfall and agile
approaches but as I mentioned earlier
you're going to need to be agile
certified even if your organization is
primarily a waterfall organization the
skills that you will learn as ace you
know in the agile scrum master course on
how to be a leader in an agile project
are going to serve you well in any
project management effort you're
involved in in fact team that it's going
to help you in your life the concepts
the tools the techniques are so powerful
that at least for me they were
life-changing it opened up a whole new
world not just professionally and
allowed me to make more money but just
being a better you
does that sound goofy to you and now you
know what I have some passion for agile
it's amazing now we mentioned that the
ASM credential increases your earning
potential I suppose you get that right
you know that that's how credentialing
works whether you like the idea of
standardized testing or not if you are
certified you make more and generally
it's between fifteen and twenty percent
more than other folks doing the same
thing that you're doing that are not
certified so if it's a game for you it's
a game but it's a 20-percent game so you
know if you want to make a hundred
thousand you know US dollars or more a
year you've got to get certified and the
ASM we're going to drill down on that
just a little bit more is one of the
best ways to demonstrate to employers
and customers that you have the
knowledge and the skills to actually do
scrum do agile so and like I said
earlier I think that it's really best to
have both now if you've already got your
PMP or your prints to doing the ASM is
the perfect next step for you as you add
to your credentials and advance in your
career if you're new to the project
management world without a doubt the
best place to start is going to be agile
and in the environment today well there
are other valid good agile
certifications out there like i
mentioned i have some of them on the ASM
is unique in a couple of ways we
mentioned one already which is the
adoption part of agile we're going to
mention another one in a minute it is
both the most specific on being a scrum
master and also the one that addresses
an organization's a viewpoint of agile
versus waterfall
uh let's see what the next slide here is
I suppose it's worth mentioning that the
reason that I think the ASM is so
important is because becoming a scrum
master is going to put you in a position
where you can participate in basically
fifty percent of all of the projects
that are in the agile world maybe I
didn't say that clearly enough what I'm
trying to say is that while there are
different agile methods scrum is the
most popular and so if you're going to
get into the agile world and you're
going to get a credential I'm
recommending that you make sure it's
focused on scrum like the ASM so scrum
has become so popular for a number of
reasons one is is that it is really easy
to understand it takes some skills and
it takes some effort but it's easy to
understand it makes sense it might be a
new way of thinking about how to get
stuff done but it makes sense it's got a
great deal of emphasis on small and
empower teams it welcomes changing and
requirement it results in shippable
software or at least potentially
shippable software at the end of each
sprint sprint by the way team is the
label of the ceremony that delivers
working software it's one of the
iterations and each sprint is going to
be like two to four weeks in duration
and that means that this is why people
love scrum is because every two to four
weeks the team is going to be delivering
software that works it can be used that
could potentially actually be released
even if it's only part of the overall
project and of course this would then
lead to the possibility of early return
on investment for the customer and then
all of this is proven and so that's why
you know most of the agile projects use
scrum
a scrum lifecycle sort of looks like
this you know you have your product
backlog you take a portion of the
product backlog and you're going to
complete that in a sprint generally
Sprint's are done like I said in a
period of two to four weeks and so
there's you know things that go on
during a sprint some on a daily basis
some not and then at the end of the
sprint you have an increment of working
software and we get into that life cycle
in the in the course so I know we're not
here to learn about it here I'm just
kind of you know just piquing your
interest a little bit about how it works
and and that we're going to cover that
and definitely do the training so let's
cover a little bit about the ASM
training in the workshop as I mentioned
you're going to learn key concepts about
a job as a management approach and scrum
specifically we're also going to cover
how to actually apply those concepts in
your real-world situation you'll learn
how scrum adds value to the development
and the delivery of high quality
projects we've touched on some of how
that is done the course is going to
cover the roles so there's three basic
roles in scrum there's the scrum master
which is what we're about there's the
product owner of a team we get into that
we cover all three roles obviously but
we drill down on the scrum master part
that's the the emphasis because we're
going to become agile scrum masters and
but we also cover the ceremonies you
know the different events that take
place what happens in them how long they
should last etc etc and the artifacts
that are used to that are part of the
scrum methodology and we also get into
what best practices to use in getting
the most value possible from using the
agile method now who should consider
taking the ASM workshop and getting
certified
asm you know we we've touched on that a
bit both chip and myself previously but
let's just review a couple these things
anybody that wants to update their
knowledge of software development a
project management is going to benefit
from this course if you're a project
management professional you're going to
drive value from the course in many
different ways for example you're going
to understand the best practices of
scrum as well as other agile methods
you'll gain deep insight into scrum and
you're going to discover how leading a
project team and delivering value to the
customers can be done in new ways using
new skills you're going to get some
practical guidance on how to implement
these practices in your organization and
how to maximize their value and it puts
you in a position to be an evangelist
and a champion of agile for your
organization we mentioned that didn't we
already that one of the things that the
ASM encompasses is adoption the other
area that is covered in the ASM that's
not the others is scaling agile one of
our modules is dedicated just the
scaling agile agile originally was for
small teams small projects but with the
use of technology and the maturation of
agile you can now do what we call
scaling agile and you can maintain all
of the benefits of agile in an
enterprise sized project so we actually
get into that in the course itself and
that's another one of the ASM benefits
that organizations will look for that
aren't a part of others let's see this
is kind of the course agenda we're going
to in Lesson one we're going to talk
about the agile way of thinking we're
going to get into some of the origins
and we're going to talk about the core
principles in the agile manifesto in
lesson 2 we're going to talk about
you know the different project
management approaches and we're going to
drill down a bit on some of the other
agile frameworks you won't be tested
much on them specifically but your
understanding of them and how they are
agile makes an enormous difference in
being able to answer some of the
questions and also be able to
demonstrate that you have a broader
knowledge of the agile world then just
sprung even though the focus is on scrum
we're part of a greater family a larger
family lesson 3 we get into the value of
scrum the scrum lifecycle we talk about
time boxing and what is time boxed and
scrum we'll talk about the various
artifacts that we use in scrum in lesson
4 we get into the roles of sprung the
development team the product owner the
scrum master and we drill down like i
said earlier into the scrum master part
of things and and some do's and don'ts
with that in lesson 5 we get into some
of the more practical things of how to
do scrum and lesson 6 has to do with
scaling agile in lesson 7 has to do with
the doffing agile the certification
itself team is you know if you go to the
eggs in website it's going to say that
you should plan on having about 120
hours of study you know maybe a little
bit less depending on your exposure to
scrum also there are case studies that
are mandatory as part of the training
that has to happen before you're
eligible to sit for the exam and we do
that in the course as well on the exam
itself is a 90-minute exam and 40
questions multiple choice questions and
all you have to do is get sixty-five
percent hundred please you know what
it's not an easy test to pass but you
know what I've been in this world of you
know project
management and training for
certifications for a long time I can
guarantee you that you're not going to
need a hundred and twenty hours of study
if you take our course on this this
course is so good at covering what needs
to be covered and getting you ready for
the exam and chip don't shoot me but I'm
going out on all in here I think all you
really need is to do the course and you
can get it done I mean maybe it'll be a
little bit of after the workshop
studying to bone up on a couple of
things we've got some practice exams to
help you do that but the course meets
the requirements to take the exam and we
give you everything you need to crack it
I mean that's what we do it's simply
there we are that the best at assisting
people to get certified you're going to
get a lot of practical value out of the
course but the main thing is right you
get that credential so you can get the
job or the position in your organization
that you want make some more money and
you know get better and better at
getting stuff done simply learn just to
touch on this and I don't know if chips
going to get into this or if you have
any questions about it but when you sign
up for one of our courses that is a
virtual course you also get access to
our learning management system so
there's online tools there's practice
tests etc and then we have a community
where you can engage with instructors
and others that are you know involved in
the same endeavor you are to learn from
each other get questions clarified etc
and it's one of the easiest tools out
there I'm going to just quickly skip
over a couple of slides here this is I
just going to show you a little bit
about what it looks like when you log in
and you will click on one of the classes
and what it looks like great tools the
simply [ __ ] source the commute tool is
great you know when you're working
on your own and you need to go someplace
and have some interaction with others
and get some questions answered it but
it goes beyond that you can get some
career related input you can get some
ideas from others you know for best
practices for actually passing the tests
etc so you're going to love this part of
our simply learn world and with that I'm
just going to go to my last slide here
with how to contact us and I'm going to
toss it back over to you chip are you
ready absolutely fantastic terrific
prezzo and and really detailed in
explaining why this is so valuable to
folks and becoming frankly just a
critical skill set for all kinds of
reasons and we do have some questions
queued up but before we do that I am
going to take over the screen for just a
moment here and not for very long
because Jeff you did a great job of
explaining kind of what simply learn is
about and what it's like to take a
course in the LMS and all of that so I
don't need to spend a lot of time
explaining to folks that if they want to
earn a certification in agile scrum that
our courses are what help you prepare
for that we do do more than just
webinars although we do lots and lots of
webinars every month on a variety of
topics and sometimes they're like today
they're about the value of certification
and sometimes they're real practical
apps kind of tactical things that cover
you know digital marketing were project
management or software development in
various specific ways but beyond the
webinars the reason we're in business is
to help you folks prepare for these
kinds of professional certifications and
that's what the training is designed to
do if you are interested in learning
more about the training and seeing a
tour of what the learning management
system looks like or getting a little
guidance in deciding which course is
right for your career goals let us know
we'll have somebody get in touch with
you there's no obligation but you'll get
a chance to see what it all looks like
and a little guidance if that's helpful
and as I say no obligation so I'm just
going to leave that pole up there for
just another couple of seconds and then
we'll jump into the questions because I
know that's why people are really here
and so on the count of three it's going
away let me know three two one here we
go so appreciate you indulging me with
that for just a second we have a few
questions queued up here and I'm going
to try to sort of consolidate those that
are similar the most common question we
get Jeff I'll actually handle this one
which is is the presentation recorded
can i watch it again later can I get a
hold of the slide deck and the answer is
yes we record all of the webinars that
we do they get produced and put up into
the system it simply learn and they are
also being pushed into our YouTube
channel so if you're not already
subscribed to the YouTube channel I
would recommend doing that and you'll be
notified when new recordings go up all
right that said you know it's it's it's
interesting you mentioned how how you're
agile and even probably your project
management training in general and your
agile in particular Jeff helps you with
just your life and teaches you skills
that you can apply to all kinds of
things and do you remember the one
minute manager or are you of an age
where you remember the one minute
manager being such a popular book I do I
remember that I remember reading the one
minute manager and thinking to myself
man you know the things that they're
talking about regarding how to manage
people are ways that I could manage my
kids be a better parent do better things
in managing my time in my life in
general and sure enough they came out
with a series of books afterwards called
one minute father and one minute mother
and and so these kinds of business and
life skills it's it's interesting how
applicable they are to so many aspects
of our lives one
the questions that we have here goes to
this to the agile scrum you talked a lot
about software development it seems like
that's what the agile scrum process
specifically was designed for but I
don't work on the IT software in I
manage projects on the business side
things like product launches with regard
to PR or sales initiatives and there's
also plenty of uncertainty there is a
July scrum the process for me or would i
be better off with waterfall or some
other method to be more applicable to
the kinds of projects i do you want me
to take that kit yeah absolutely go
ahead so um that is a great question and
the answer is is that it's really not
mutually exclusive so there's going to
be value in both but because of what
you're talking about product launches
and marketing there is a lot of
uncertainty in changing things there so
the ability to know and understand scrum
is going to serve you better for those
kinds of projects than it will be for
just waterfall I think if it were me I
would start with the ASM and then
consider backfilling with you the
prince2 or with the PMP and I might just
mention another thing too because this
question prompted me to remember that
there's something I probably should have
said earlier and that is while agile is
primarily you know got its genesis in
the software world consumer electronics
is a big place where a July sits in you
know the development of you know
wearables and smartphones and other
hardware devices where there is software
involved but the actual hardware changes
significantly in trying to leapfrog
ahead of the competition that's also
where agile fits in perfect yeah you
mentioned several times that you would
recommend getting both waterfall and
agile and so and I think it makes sense
that that it's it's going to be
appropriate to kind of double dip
and you're right I didn't think about
that the products like electronics or
cell phones and smart TVs and things
like that man they're constantly
competing to put new products out and
add new features and and what have you
seems like virtually every industry is
is having to be more and more
competitive in the consumer product
space is there a particular sector that
you see growth in opportunities for
project management especially in that
kind of agile environment beyond
software dev financial or health care or
manufacturing at large I think in the
service industry as well because
technology is a part of that but also
going beyond the the technology meaning
the software that goes into it being
able to deliver to an organization or an
individual a service that can be
changing and adaptable to whatever that
person needs you know whatever they're
trying to deliver with the service that
fits well into the agile world as well
and it hasn't been so much in the past
start of a software it's gone into like
consumer electronics and now it's
shifting into things like the service
industry and even things like running
political campaigns and we you know we
mentioned the marketing and things like
that the agile approach is well suited
for that you mentioned political
campaigns we've had a couple of
presentations and talking about on the
market motive side the sister company to
simply learn where we really focus on
digital marketing we've had some some
presentations there in the form of
webinars about big data and how that's
being used you know to really do the
data mining of voters and whatnot in the
political arena and how that's really
changing things and putting those two
things together of being able to have
the agile experience and skill set along
with working with big data it's a really
powerful combination I'm sure
is project management someone is asking
here a career path appropriate to
someone who wants to work as a private
contractor or most of the opportunities
on in-house teams and organizations I
think it's critical if you're going to
be a consultant or work on your own I am
engaged in a lot of real-world projects
right now and as a consultant and also
as a consumer and project management was
part of that and the first thing I look
for certifications and whether you're
going to do your own business is a
consultant or whether you're going to be
engaging with them certification is
going to make all the difference in the
world excellent appreciate that I hope
that answered your question there folks
and you get a nice breakdown of what the
training looks like inside of simply
learned I don't know if we saw there how
many hours altogether the training
process is before you get to doing the
certification test with xyn how how many
classroom hours so to speak are there in
the simply learn agile scrum training so
there's going to be 16 hours of formal
training and what we usually do is we
break up the virtual classes in 24 for
our segments in we do a lot of these on
weekends so like four hours on a
saturday for hours on a sunday and then
the next weekend another four hours on
Saturday and another four hours on the
sunday but we also have some practice
tests and online tools in what we do is
we give you some guidance on how to know
when you're ready to sign up to actually
write the exam and so we get into a
little bit about the how to pass a
standardized test and depending on how
you do based on the metrics that we
share with you you may want to do some
more studying and spend some extra time
with our practice exams
some will be ready to write the exam
right after and so it's basically a
16-hour formal effort with some of the
homework that's involved not a ton but
we do have some homework and for some
you know at the end of that whole
process there might be a need to do some
more studying and working with the
practice tests but the core thing is the
16 hours plus the homework and then
dealing with the practice tests to know
whether you're ready to write the
examiner perfect i really appreciate you
mentioning there that it's weekends too
because obviously you know the folks
that are working with us here at simply
learned you're all working professionals
already and you've got careers and jobs
and lives and so we try to to organize
our schedule around around your life and
make things available to you you know at
the appropriate time when folks are
sitting for the the certification test
is you gave us a great breakdown of kind
of how many questions what the passing
percentages are these essay questions or
multiple choice questions what is the
what does the test look like it is 40
multiple choice questions with four
possibilities a B C or D the questions
are more scenario based so that to
answer a single question you need to
have an understanding of a number of
things in order to get down to the
correct answer and we'll chat in the the
course a bit about how you actually deal
with sorting through the questions and
there are some good test taking skills
that will allow you to go through the
process of getting to the correct answer
for example one of the tools we'll talk
about that will serve you well is doing
the process of elimination when you do a
standardized test that makes more sense
to see which answers you can throw out
you know eliminate than to just focus on
what the correct answer is which is sort
of counterintuitive but that's one of
the reasons we're so good at simply
learn is
we not only cover the material insist
you in your will roll the application
that we also help you know how to
actually pass the exam so you get the
credit credential that's perfect thank
you for that I hope that helped Mohamed
I have time to squeeze in one more
question here I think and then I'm going
to share some links with you folks too
so stick around and keep an eye on the
chat module here in just a second and
I'll share some links in there for you
as well but we'll squeeze in one more
question here let me pick the best one
that everybody's going to really benefit
from let's do it let's do a career
skills question here so if I'm a working
project management professional and I'm
trying to present myself well on
linkedin aside from just adding which
certifications that I've earned you have
any other advice for how to present
myself well on linkedin is it
appropriate to list a bunch of specific
projects that I've managed or is it
better to focus on which business brands
I've worked with how can I present
myself best on linkedin well this is me
and there may be others that have a
different opinion on this but when i'm
on linkedin and i'm looking for somebody
I don't care as much what company they
work for I want to know what they did so
I know you can't share proprietary
information but I'm looking for projects
they've worked on and what was involved
in the project so I can discern whether
they have experience using the skills
and the tools and the techniques that I
know are going to be important for my
project so that's my approach there that
makes perfect sense and yeah I can
imagine that there are some some privacy
issues you know you don't want to give
away any details of the projects that
you've worked on that might be
proprietary information but at least the
sort of project that is that makes total
sense perfect i appreciate that folks
take a look at the chat module here i'm
sharing in a series of links for you and
what this is is a couple of shortcuts to
some of the project management and agile
scrum courses that we
have available whoops I'm sorry my my my
coffee says that it's AWS and security
links but they're not they're links to
project management so take a look at
that there's a link to the project
management courses a link to the agile
and scrum courses there's also a link to
a series of upcoming webinars and
resources focused on agile scrum so
you'll see there some some materials and
articles about building your career
there that might be helpful as well and
lastly there's a couple of links on a
couple of upcoming agile scrum demos so
if you want to participate in a webinar
like this that is a demo of what the
class is going to look like and it'll
show you what the LMS operates like and
what it's like to be in a class there
are two upcoming demos in August on
agile scrum one on august seventeenth
and one on august 30th and these are at
730am central time I believe so go ahead
and click through and take a look at
those and join us if you can Jeff that's
it we're at the end of our hour we've
actually gone two whole minutes over
thank you so much for your time today
you are welcoming to the team can I just
say good luck in your careers I wish you
the best and I hope our paths cross
again and that we can be of some mutual
benefit I'm sure that'll be the case and
as well from myself thanks to everybody
for joining us and I know that for some
of you it might have been in the middle
of the night or late into the evening so
thanks for making time in your busy
schedules and you're welcome Richard
says thank you Jeff he enjoyed what you
had to offer and with that will wish you
a terrific rest of your morning
afternoon or evening wherever you are
folks thank you Jeff for hanging out
with us today and thank you everyone
else as well have a great day and we'll
talk to you next time take care folks
bye bye
you